anime tropes we love to hate
it's a guy
it is now High School
how'd you guys do we hate it I hate it
yes I do
I
um the moment I see an anime now and
it's like he's a normal high school
like cyberpunk 2077 I nearly clocked out
when he was in school because I was like
do you mean age Runners uh sure yeah
yeah sorry Edge Runners yeah uh when he
was in school I was like I swear to
[__] God if they've made a cyberpunk
and they put it in a [__] school I'm
gonna lose it and then of course he
leaves school that episode yeah thank
God but like I'm just so over anything
with high school I think I've said this
before in the anime yeah yeah bored yeah
how okay how do we feel because this is
one of the this is one of the things
that's like parodied the most but like
the over explanations when it comes to
anime fights oh the sex machine
and let's take Jojo and Becky out of
this conversation because I feel like
those are like those are so ridiculous I
need the explanation yes of course I I
need them so like you're talking about
like say like in a in a Sports Anime for
example where like as as you know this
like second by second play is happening
some guy in the [__] crowd has an ex
has time to do a three minute
explanation or not like sports time or
even like any Shonen battle anime yeah
I do like the hunter narration though I
don't know something about it it's gone
realized he [__] up
I don't I don't know I I think it's just
like so commonplace now where I just
don't think about it anymore I do think
it's
like kind of lazy I feel like if you're
if you make it interesting you can
convey all this information without
needing to tell the audience right yeah
show don't tell right yeah yeah because
because I I was thinking about this
because I think it's just something
we've accepted that anime just [__]
does you know this is this is just a
thing we're gonna explain what's
happening
um and it's not only until like recently
when we've just seen examples where it's
been handled better than it has in the
past like I think uh I think Jujutsu
Kyson has had a really good balance
between showing what's happening versus
like explaining what's happening
um and I recently did like a video on
like manga adaptations and I realized
I I've realized what difference it makes
when you just take out the explanation
uh take out the explaining and just show
what's happening on screen and it's just
like holy [__] this works so much better
it just takes so much more effort yeah
but so few anime actually go out and do
it yeah and that's the problem right is
that like some of the best stories in
Manga and Anime uh you know don't
require a whole lot of explanation or
even dialogue to like tell you what's
happening like you know like blam for
example right like that blogger has
barely any dialogue at all but it's
still coherent enough because it shows
you every step of the way visually and
as long as you can like kind of put the
pieces together as to like the sequence
of what's Happening then it's [__]
epic but the problem is as you said it
just takes more brain power to figure
out what's happening because it's very
much open to interpretation right so I
think they've just like yeah maybe it is
laziness I don't know maybe they maybe
the authors just have decided being like
well I could show them but at the same
time I'm afraid to alienate any readers
into what exactly is happening and it
might you know deter them from enjoying
the rest of the story it comes from
manga right so I think it's that's why
we often get this over explanation kind
of approach to it because because you
need it yeah
there's so many
so many manga that have shown in manga
that I really struggle to see what's
going on in the fight yeah like I don't
know am I the only person who has this
problem no there are some fights where
I'm just like I don't know what the
[__] happening there are some manga
that are better than others um sometimes
I just I I I am looking at the Battle
and I am I am re reading the panels like
going over it four times and I'm like I
still in my head cannot figure out what
you you read Claymore didn't you yeah I
read all of Claymore that was hard holy
[__] because I I
um I've like I've reread it like
recently um and that was almost [__]
impossible to discern what's happening
because later fights yeah because like
in group fights you have like all of
these Claymore where all of them are
like silver heads uh silver head women
wearing the same [__] uniform and I'm
like who is even fighting right now I
jet I actually cannot tell who's
Swinging The Sword yeah it's just it's
that that one was like but I think
that's the thing right it's like it's
it's it's all up to the the different
author on like their skill on being able
to like show the flow of movement right
like the reason why I like berserk for
example like Mira did such a good job on
that is that like a lot of the fights
don't really have an explanation right
and if and if there is an explanation
it's maybe like one or two frames right
yeah but he was such he was such a
master the joke was really easy to find
because he was such a master at like
figuring out the flow of movement and
like where to show it and how to show it
that it was just very self-explanatory
even in like big fights right Claymore
was hard to follow yeah yeah even though
the Claymore has amazing [__] art
like the monster designing Claymore was
like incredible yeah uh but the way the
story went because of the story because
of how the story was structured around a
group of people who basically are look
exactly the same and uh or dress exactly
the same yeah and have the same kind of
weapons just
I really like that yeah cool yeah it was
a really cool it was a really cool world
check it out if you haven't yeah it was
quite good but stopped don't don't the
anime had a original ending remember
when anime had like remember when the
anime just went its own part I think it
was gonna like and I was like I'm gonna
do my own thing I'm gonna end it myself
anyway is the part up until like the
halfway point yeah the first time yeah
yeah
um because there's no High School in it
so that's right what do you hate about
Heist is there a single anime that's
based in high school that is like I can
forgive this yeah like I I mean okay
there are a lot of shows where it makes
a lot of sense and I I've gone on this
rant before and there's a lot of shows
where I just feel like if anything it
detracts from it
um like obviously
um like you know uh light being a high a
college student or a high school student
as well I have no qualms about that they
make sense in the story it uh you know
adds to the reason why you'd never
suspect this character to be doing this
stuff this is a normal high school
student but there's other ones where I'm
just like like Tokyo Revengers did do
they really need to be high school
students like straight up like that show
is I've seen they were Middle School
students was like I I went on this whole
land when we talked about this before
but Tokyo Avengers I was actually ruined
for me because they are all middle
schools yeah it's like it makes the show
so much [__] I don't understand why
they did that but it's such an
interesting dichotomy isn't it because
we say that about Tokyo Avengers and yet
we're okay with hanayama from Baki being
14. is it it's such a weird life they're
all high school students but like it's
like not even the heat the main
characters high school student fighting
like fully grown men yeah yeah it's
literally nothing in back he makes any
sense so it doesn't matter he's
literally never in school no he's a high
school student he was he's the worst
high school student in Japan he's never
how is that man not expelled I don't
like it he is never at school where are
the police I guess they but do you think
the police are going to stop him the
[__] U.S military at one point I
don't think it's an issue I'm sorry if
there's a high if if if in this world
the U.S military comes and talks to a
high school student about like asking
him to not fight because he's basically
a weapon of mass destruction I think all
other normal rules go out the window
um unless and your dad just talked to
Obama the other day we discussed this I
think the series that like I think the
series that Jarred me the most in terms
of like adding High School in it
um is this is a pretty old one actually
it's a awari no Seraph
um yeah yeah do you remember this one
like I really like this show but I like
the show as well no but but like I said
like I remember the first like two or
three episodes we we introduced to this
like post-apocalyptic world where
vampires are taken over and there's only
like sex of humanity [__] yeah and it's
like it's a [__] amazing world this
the main character wakes up and he's
like wait he finds out that he's just
like food for the vampires he has to
escape and all this and you're like damn
this world's metal he escapes finds like
the freedom Squad the revolutionaries
the Lost remaining humans
and then there's a [__] high school
Arc and I'm just like you're in a
post-apocalyptic World [__] you
have tried really [__] hard you have
to try really [__] hard to completely
forgot about it yeah dude to like bring
High School into this but you've managed
it somehow and I don't know why you
thought this was a good idea and it's so
weird because later on they pretty much
just drop that all anyway so I don't
under like that okay that was a show
that I think that really like plagued it
like because it was when it first came
out it was like really um especially the
anime like people were freaking out
about it yeah it just dropped after
Attack on Titan had a similar kind of
edginess to it if I were looking for I
think it just yeah the high school kind
of element ruined it yeah it's like it's
like the equivalent of if like halfway
through season one of Attack on Titan
they just like go back to school yeah
and just realized it was like let's just
[__] make these children grow up yeah
they should actually have like a good
[__] dollar
oh yeah it's yeah it's I you know I
would I would like for more stories to
be set outside of high school and I
think with slowly starting to see that I
don't know or at least or at least like
if it's going to be in a high school get
it to the point where you know we get to
see them once they're out of school or
something you know like or once they're
like you know like B stars did a really
good job of that where like it starts
off in a school but then the second half
he's not in the school anymore and he's
like out in the real world and like that
I think like balance is cool I don't
mind that a lot of people always argue
they're like it's more relatable to the
the target audience yes and I'd say what
aspect of jotaro do I relate to because
him being a 17 year old kid as a high
school student I mean like I feel this
argument of it being more targeted is
like there's a reason why Jose is the
only JoJo that was in a high school yeah
right right like even even [__] uh
Jose uh even Joe Tara right like even
though he's a high school student you
never see him in the first right like I
find that they spend a lot of shows
where they have a high school
protagonist often spend no time in high
school anyway so what's the point of
even bringing this up just and sometimes
I I find that kids aren't that [__]
dumb I feel like people think kids are
so much more stupid than they are that
if it's just not the same if they're not
in the exact same situation they can't
relate or have some kind of tie to it
and it's like yes obviously when I was
in school and Harry Potter was going on
that was something I could relate to a
lot more and that was a banger but yeah
it wasn't like I didn't want to watch 24
and Jack Bauer go around shooting people
you know what I mean like I yeah I find
that kids want those other stories
anyway so stop saying that the only
reason is because they're targeting high
school students well it's it's fine that
they don't they're not that dumb in the
case with Japan it's it goes both ways
it's it's the fact that yes they're
trying to Target high school students
who are currently in high school where
it's like oh this character I like is
also in high school I relate but it's
also targeted towards younger adults who
have just come out of high school as
well where because to a lot of Japanese
people this idea of like in high school
and being a student was kind of like a
golden age right otherwise the saddest
thing which is a really sad but it's but
it's the true
which is which is weird right because
it's this I'm pretty sure I've talked
about it before but anyway yeah it's
this weird like difference in between
the west and Japan of like in Japan high
school is like a time where it's like I
wish I was back there and then in the
west high schools movies and stuff like
that are always like look how [__] high
school was can you relate guys being an
adult is so much better yeah and it's
just this like weird dichotomy so it's
like I get that sometimes they want to
do it for that purpose but I also do
agree that a lot of the times they just
throw it into a [__] high school
because like oh that's an easy setting I
don't have to come up with like an
original concept for a setting or a
world yeah and then minus double points
if it's in a school and then there's
unnecessary lewdness all the time or fan
service but they're just like groping
each other and you're like what I mean
that's literally every energy Monger in
anime I know yeah I mean most of that
most of that has been transferred over
to the fantasy genre now I think most
for sure I think High School edgy has uh
I don't know if
okay I I get it it's your it's your
fantasy world and a lot of like medieval
stories and they had slaves in them but
also it's a fantasy world it's a it's
it's what you're only limited by what
your mind can imagine and why does
everyone imagine slavery in their world
what's going on like why are we trying
to bring this back
it's just
we knew Easter guys the way I watched
now it's just like oh there's the
rescuing the slave walk is he just go is
he going to free the slave this time or
is he going to take the slave under his
own arms
the slave is falling in love with it
claiming that he's a savings
I mean I'm white so I don't want to talk
too much
but a lot of the time she feels like
well we got this character who's kind of
just cool how do we kind of make him
more likeable yeah
just give just give him a savior complex
as well